Tổng thủ của quay nào, bố lột đi miê ra lên kia ngay mùa bài thủ miê hà cho biết
Các quốc chào đổi với đại dẫn Mỹ về dự thảo hoa bình thông dễ dàng dân có tiền trên
Ông là phía Mỹ hiểu gió lấp chương có ló của quay nào, đông thời hà bình đã thống nất các bước tiếp theo
và khun cố cho vọng đà phản sắp tới
Chương đó, mẹ lên đạm với các đặc phải viên của tổng thủ Mỹ là 스티q quý khóc
và cho đất khu xin ở, cuộc chào đổi tập trung có những yêu két nhằm chống dứt rau trang
và ngăn viên cơ ngà mở chính giết cận công mời
Ông cụt thử nhận còn nhiều lỗi dụng ngày càm, không thể thảo lật của đến thoại
Tổng thống không cùng ngày nói, hơi chất bọng bị người đồng cấp của quay nào
Chưa đọng đầy đủ để xất hoa bình mà Washington đưa ra
Hẹn các tấp cận trong việc chăm dứt xung đồ của Mỹ đàng khám với cho ông
Washington thì một túc đầy một thảo thật nháng và chia sẽ cạnh nặng
trong khi các nước EU một tên trình tình bức, gặp với duy trì hỗ trợ quân sự cho kia
về kia ngà, mắt tư vạc hàng định sẽ sạm đà phản theo dụng thảo bình tình trình
và các buộc của quay nào của phương tây đàng cạnh cho hoa bình
Khi et mắt mỏ trong khi cho ông nói mắt tư vạc đàng của kéo dài thời gian để cùng của lợi thế trên thực đia
Ông dễ ngay sĩ cũng dự kiến gặp lãnh đạo anh pháp và đất
tại lần đầu ngày 18, mẹ tục thuốc đầy đảm phán